- Hi, everyone.
Sal Khan here.
Welcome to the homeroom livestream.
We have a really exciting
guest today, Pedro Noguera,
who is the Dean of the
Rossier School of Education
at University of Southern California.
So start thinking of your questions,
putting them on the message
board on YouTube or Facebook,
wherever you're watching this.
And we're gonna try to get
as many questions as possible
to Dean Noguera about
all things education,
higher education, what's going on in K-12,
I think all of that is fair game.
Whatever is of interest to you.
But before we jump into that conversation,
I'll give my standard announcements.
First of all, a reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization.
We only exist through
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making a donation
at khanacademy.org/donate.
Also want to give a special
shout out to several
organizations that
stepped up when COVID hit.
And we saw that our costs had gone up
because we were seeing
250% of normal usage,
and we were trying to accelerate
a whole series of programs.
So special, thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, fastly, Novartis,
and the many other funders at all levels,
including many of y'all,
for helping keep Khan Academy going.
We continue to need your help.
So once again, if you're
in a position to do so,
please think about making a donation.
Last but not least,
reminder for everyone about
Homeroom with Sal, the podcast,
wherever you can find your podcast.
It's an audio version of
some of the highlights
from this livestream that you can consume
safely in your car.
So encourage you to check that out.
So with that,
I'm excited to introduce Pedro Noguera,
Dean of the Rossier School
of Education at USC.
Pedro, thanks for joining us.
- Thanks for having me,
Sal, great to be with you.
- So there is a ton to talk about,
maybe the best place to start.
I mean, I wanna talk about given
you're in higher education,
but you're in higher education
at the school of education,
I think you have a really interesting lens
on both higher education and K-12.
Big picture, where do you think we are
on the COVID crisis and education?
What's gonna be the main damage done
and what are the big opportunities?
- Wow, so, so much damage.
We just released a report today
from USC showing the impact
of virtual learning on
kids, just in the LA area.
And there are still
thousands of kids who have
uneven or real total lack of
access to virtual learning.
And that's not been corrected.
And I'm not faulting the
district 'cause they did
and have gone to great lengths
to try to get screens to kids
and to connect it to the internet.
But we still have lots of
communities across the country,
particularly in rural areas,
but urban areas as well,
where there's no internet service.
So it starts there, just no access.
Then we have the fact that
there are, as we know,
many affluent people are
able to put their kids
into learning pods, they
get hired private tutors,
there're independent schools
where kids are coming back.
That's not happening for
kids who are dependent on
the public schools, especially
in our low income districts.
So the disparities that were
there before the pandemic,
are gonna be worse after.
- And I guess, two questions.
Is there anything we can do to help
mitigate some of that damage?
Or if we're not, how do we deal with it
once we do normalize,
whatever that might be?
- Well, I start by just
reminding the viewers,
all along several of us have been saying,
we have fixated on the wrong thing.
We were calling this an achievement gap,
when we should have been always framing it
as an opportunity gap.
That is that kids need
the opportunity to learn.
And that means once you frame it that way,
then you start to look at the conditions
under which teaching and learning occur.
Those conditions have been very uneven,
and all our fixation on test scores
has never addressed that.
We never have made sure, for example,
that kids have access to capable teachers,
that they're in schools
with lab equipment,
and libraries, basic
things that kids need.
And now we have the issues of
access around online learning.
And again, if you're an affluent
kid and something is hard,
you can get a private tutor,
you can go onto Khan Academy.
Now, hopefully Khan Academy
is available to everybody,
but there are a lot of kids
who don't have those resources.
And so my hope is that
policymakers will become much more
attentive to these gaps in opportunity
that are pervasive
throughout American society.
- Speaking about the opportunity
gap, I couldn't agree more.
I mean, the digital divide
is the most obvious one,
especially during COVID,
when you need that
to just even be able to
access your potential.
But even outside of COVID,
if you have even a handful
of kids in the classroom
who don't have internet access at home
or proper internet access,
the whole classroom's
not going to be able to
take advantage of
personalized learning tools
or whatever else.
And then I was surprised, I
remember several months ago
reading a report, that a
majority of minority majority
schools don't even offer, high schools,
don't offer a lot of the
courses that we take for granted
in a high school.
And when they do offer it,
they don't cover it at
the same level of rigor
'cause their expectations, arguably
whatever something's going on,
they might not be having
the same level of equipment,
the same level of expertise
amongst some of the
faculty, we don't know.
But these kids aren't
getting the opportunity
to even engage at that level.
What do you see as the major levers?
If you were secretary of education
or emperor of the universe,
what would you do to help close that?
- Well, I think it has to go
beyond secretary of education.
I think the federal
government, state governments,
should be leaning hard on
the high tech companies.
These companies are the
richest companies in the world
right now, and have gotten
richer even during the pandemic.
You think about Amazon, Facebook, Google,
these companies are
massive, they're large.
They have a social
responsibility to invest in
the infrastructure that allows access.
If you think about it, telephone service
would not be available in rural areas,
if we just saw it as a cost.
We recognized that there's a basic need
and right to communication.
And so therefore, we do have cell towers
and telephone service, even in
the most remote rural areas.
We need that kind of
a commitment to access
to basic services around the country.
I think the federal
government has to lean in,
and we might need legislation,
but we've got to figure out
a way to make that possible,
because not only is it about
learning opportunities,
but as we know, we rely on the
internet for everything now.
And to see so many people
cut off is I think again,
a reflection of the deep
and persistent inequality
in our country.
- No, you're absolutely right.
In all of the opportunity
gaps that need to be filled,
I mean, the most obvious
one especially during COVID,
is clearly the digital divide.
And I mean, any sense,
we're signatories to this
Connect All Students campaign,
that Common Sense Media is doing.
And you know, my back of the
envelope calculations are
you could connect all the
families that aren't connected,
in the whole country,
for 1% of one of the rounds
of stimulus that were.
So it feels like the most
obvious thing in the world to do.
And it economically empowers people,
probably even improves
their health outcomes
'cause they'll get access
to information and whatnot.
What's your view from how,
what are teachers seeing and feeling,
and how might, do you think
what we're seeing in COVID
is it's just a COVID thing?
Or do you think there's
certain aspects of teaching
or schooling that might be forever altered
because of what we're going through?
- Well I think, I was
just on a call yesterday
with some teachers in Texas, San Antonio.
And many of them, their primary concern
was the mental health needs of kids,
and the stress that they're
seeing their children under.
Kids who are not going outside,
kids who are depressed and anxious
because of the climate in the country.
And I'm worried about the longterm effects
and consequences of that.
You also have the same
kinds of stress on teachers.
Just think about the teachers
who are juggling kids at home,
while they're expected
to do Zoom instruction.
So unfortunately when you're
preoccupied with those things,
how do you get creative
on the use of Zoom,
and online platforms to provide
really high quality instruction?
There are some schools
that are doing that,
they provided the support
and guidance to teachers,
but I think that that's not
happening nearly enough.
And so what we're seeing
as many kids who get,
they're discouraged,
they're not motivated,
they're burnt out from
too many hours online,
and they're giving up.
And that worries me, especially
for the older students
who should be preparing
for college right now.
- No, that makes a ton of sense.
I mean, what if you were able,
we have a lot of teachers who watch this.
What would you tell them?
I mean, as you just described,
there's a lot of stressors going on,
and they're trying to,
they're doing heroic efforts.
What advice would you have for them
to kinda navigate all of this?
- I would strongly encourage
them to go onto Edutopia.
That's my favorite platform
because they provide
very practical guidance to
teachers, on first of all,
how do you provide social
and emotional support to kids
in an online medium?
How do you design good
lessons K through 12,
in a variety of subjects for kids,
that can get kids engaged
and help kids to develop
their skills and ensure
that learning is occurring?
So you need those kinds of hands-on tools
available for teachers.
Many districts don't have
the resources to provide it.
So unfortunately, it falls
on the back of teachers
to figure out where can
I get the help I need?
But there's help available there.
And I'd really encourage
you to go check it out
if you're a teacher out
there listening, Edutopia.
I don't get paid.
So this is a free commercial.
I just think it's great.
- No, they're a not-for-profit,
that's George Lucas's effort.
And I'm also a very big fan of them.
So we're aligned there.
Are there going to be some fallout?
I mean, we've talked about
some of the negatives
that are gonna happen over,
I mean, frankly were
already happening pre-COVID,
and if anything, COVID's
making it worse around
opportunity gaps and digital divide.
Do you think that people have,
obviously your traditional
standardized state assessments
have had to go on hold because of COVID,
every teacher I talk to,
they're thinking about
how do they use Zoom in
a more interactive way.
People are getting creative
in terms of breakout sessions,
use of things like Khan Academy.
Do you think that some
of this is going to,
people are right now are
doing hybrids, where even if,
when they are coming back to school,
there's gonna be some
kids that are still home,
so how do you support both?
Do you think any of that stuff
is gonna last post-COVID?
Or do you think we're just gonna go back
to what we were doing before?
- That's a good question,
and something I've been
thinking a lot about.
I think ideally, this disruption
should serve as an opportunity
to do things differently
and hopefully better than we were before,
that we don't just return
to schools as we knew them.
For too many kids, school was not a place
where they felt supported,
where they felt stimulated and challenged.
We need that to be the primary focus.
If you think about it,
I just did a conversation with the former
Secretary of Education a few days ago,
No Child Behind got us
fixated on achievement
as measured by test scores,
which then directed teachers
to prepare kids for tests.
That to me, was such a
disservice to education
because what we know is that teaching,
when it's powerful, should be creative,
it should be stimulating,
it should be engaging,
it should be meaningful.
And as a former teacher myself,
I taught in Providence, Rhode Island,
when I first started.
I taught history, and I loved history.
And I knew then that my job
was not simply to cover the textbook.
My job was to make history come to life,
so that students would appreciate
and want to learn more history.
And that's a message
I often tell teachers.
We know we're doing it
right when kids want more.
That's the way knowledge works.
You want more once you start to realize
the power of knowledge.
Well that's what we've
got to come back to.
We've gotta redirect the
attention of our teachers.
Their jobs should be to get
kids excited about learning,
to focus on motivation, to
focus on making it meaningful,
rather than simply covering material
and assessing to see if kids got it.
That to me was.
I mean, I get it.
We needed the evidence
that kids were learning.
We just focused on the wrong things.
- And you feel that post-COVID,
there might be some
opportunities to rethink this
because some of the traditional
kind of testing structures
have, or at least that
they've been paused,
in some of the state assessments.
- And also in ESS, Every Student Succeeds,
replaced No Child Behind,
gives states more flexibility
to do things differently.
To do formative assessments
and performance based assessment.
So we don't have to allow
the assessment itself
to be the driving factor.
But what I see is that in several states,
I don't see the vision
or the knowledge about
how to do things differently,
and that worries me.
If you look at the independent schools,
they're already doing it differently.
Many of the affluent public schools are.
Where we see the problems
is in the schools
serving low income kids,
which are over half the
kids in the country today.
That's where we see the kind
of kill and drill approach
that I think leaves many kids alienated.
- No, it makes sense.
So we have a question here from a teacher,
Christina Espinosa.
Good day, Dr. Noguera.
I am a teacher in the Sweetwater
Union High School District.
Currently, we are teaching 100% virtually
and serving students from
extremely diverse backgrounds.
Since we see students
throughout several zip codes
from a rather fluent East Chula Vista,
all the way down to the border,
we can not have a one size
fits all grading policy.
How, from your experience,
should we approach grading?
- Good question.
And hello to the folks down at Sweetwater.
They have literally hundreds
of kids, I think each day,
at least when schools were open,
were coming across the
border to go to school.
Some kids getting up
at three in the morning
to get to school, so I
just wanna acknowledge
the efforts of those kids and
the educators who serve them.
I think grading all along,
and I've been struggling with this
as a university professor for many years.
What we forget is the real
learning is not in the grade
you earn, it's in your
ability to demonstrate
how much you've learned,
it's the work you produce.
So we should be using grading
to give feedback to students,
meaningful feedback on how to improve.
And we should be treating work
as in an iterative manner,
that is the real learning
occurs through the revision.
Of getting it right, or
getting it improving upon
the finished product.
And so what always has concerned
about the way we do grading
in schools, is kids get
fixated on the grade.
Some kids want the A and
so they'll aim for the A's.
Some kids just wanna pass.
And what we should be more
concerned about is the learning.
How much have they learned?
What can they share
with us and demonstrate
is proof of what they've learned?
That's what we should be looking at.
And that's what, to the
degree that we need to affix
a grade at the end, we should
grade evidence of growth,
evidence of mastery, because
when we don't focus on that,
what we end up with is
kids who are pushed along
grade by grade, who
have a weak foundation,
who can't do very much, end
up in college, can't write,
can't do research, even
though they passed.
And that is a huge problem.
- I couldn't agree more.
One of the things that
I talk a lot about is
70% of kids that show
up at community college
have to take remedial
math, which you know,
is not a euphemism for
11th or 12th grade math.
It's pre-algebra, it's
sixth or seventh grade math.
So the whole system, to
your point, year after year
kids promoted, they get 20%
wrong on dividing decimals,
they get 30% wrong on exponents,
those gaps just keep accumulating.
At some point, the algebra is hard.
They start watering it down for them,
so that they have the
illusion of progress.
You get to college, and they're saying,
you're not even ready
to learn algebra yet,
which is really a ninth
or 10th grade subject.
And those kids, all of them are capable
'cause we get letters from them everyday
when they go back and fill in their gaps,
they're all capable of it.
But it's incredibly disheartening,
and we know that's the
weeder, or the best predictor
of not succeeding in
college is having to show up
and having to take a noncredit
bearing remedial courses.
I mean, with that lens, how do you see,
and everything that we do at Khan Academy
is trying to facilitate mastery learning.
So I love your view there.
But what's your sense of college?
There's a question from YouTube (mumbles).
Do you think college
will change in the future
because of the pandemic?
- College is gonna have to change.
And the main thing that
has to change is the cost.
It's out of reach for too many people.
We have too many students
that have to take on debts
that they'll incur and be
paying back well into adulthood
because the cost of
college has gone too high.
So we've gotta figure
out how to reduce costs,
how to increase access, but
also how to improve teaching.
So it's very easy.
We often, in the
conversations about teaching
and the critiques, we focus on K-12,
but I would say some of
the worst teaching I see
is at the university level,
where the primary mode of
teaching is still lecture.
And lecture, even if you're
a very good lecturer,
is not the most effective way
for students to learn something.
We need to know real,
get the evidence again.
Evidence-based teaching is
a much more interactive.
Let me just use the one example,
going back to math and
algebra that you gave.
When I was in eighth grade, I
took algebra with my teacher,
Ms. Harris, in New York City.
And Ms. Harris started class by saying,
you kids are lucky
'cause I'm the best teacher in the school.
She said, tell me who
out there in this class
struggles in math?
And very sheepishly I raised my hand
because I was fine in arithmetic,
but algebra was throwing me for a loop.
So she said, you kids
are gonna sit in front.
'Cause I'm going to check
on you throughout the day
and everyday to make sure you with me.
'Cause she understood
that if you didn't get it
in September, you certainly
wouldn't have it by June.
She was constantly looking at our work,
she wanted proof that we got it.
She was inviting our
questions, not to embarrass us,
but make sure that we were with her.
It was interactive.
And because of that, I
came out of that course
much more confident about my knowledge
and understanding of math.
When we teach that way, in
that kind of interactive way,
when we recognize that teaching
and learning are connected,
and Khan Academy does
this better than I think
most people, then what learning becomes
an exercise in acquiring and
becoming and getting ownership
of the information, material, the skills,
instead of a passive experience
of sitting through lessons.
And that I think, is the
biggest change at both
the university and at the K-12 level
that we need to bring about.
- It's fascinating 'cause
these days during COVID,
with everyone learning
on video conference,
everyone's like how do
we make it engaging?
'Cause kids are going on
different window, video windows,
and everyone's saying that
you gotta ask them questions,
you gotta be on top of them,
you gotta pull them out of the screen,
put them into breakouts.
And it's always like by the way,
that's also a good idea when
you're in a physical classroom.
Your point about mastery learning,
it sounds like you had a great teacher,
who intuitively got that
you can't let these kids
have the gaps because it becomes
a self-fulfilling prophecy.
If you don't know how to dribble,
you can practice free throws all day.
You're not gonna be a
great basketball player.
But somehow the system, and
I don't blame the system,
because it's the best
way we knew how to do it
200 years ago, but there's now.
To your point, your
teacher was able to do it
with pretty low tech, so
maybe we could have done it
a little bit different awhile ago.
- She said I'm the best teacher.
And best teacher to her,
meant not that she taught the best kids,
best teacher meant she could
teach all kinds of kids.
See, and that's also a shift
in the way we think about teaching.
There are a lot of people out
there who think they're good,
but they're only good with
kids who don't need help.
They only wanna teach honors.
They only wanna teach AP.
They don't wanna teach kids who struggle.
And that's part of the problem,
that real teaching is about
helping to make it accessible,
make it, get it, help kids to get it.
So I think the shift needs
to occur on both ends,
in how we deliver, but also
how we engage students.
If I can just use one analogy.
If you watch kids when
they're playing a video game,
a new game, if they need
help, they don't get it,
they go on YouTube, they call a friend,
that's part of learning.
Then they're making mistakes
because that's part of learning, too.
You learn through your mistakes.
And then they advance.
They advance because they
get better and better.
And then they master the game.
That's the way learning occurs for kids.
And that's what we should be
replicating in our classrooms.
A version of that.
- I couldn't agree more.
That's what we aspire
exactly to help facilitate.
It was a good question here
from YouTube, Niche786.
You're widely known for
your work on equity,
race, and poverty issues in education.
How do you see social emotional learning
fitting into those areas?
If schools aren't addressing racism,
they aren't fully addressing
trauma, in quotes.
How can schools better align their work
in these related areas?
- So, one of the things we
know, all teachers know this,
kids learn through relationships.
Kids will learn from teachers
they know care about them,
who are invested in them.
And caring doesn't mean we
have to be best buddies.
My teacher, Ms. Harris,
wasn't my best buddy.
She let me know that
if you're in my class,
you're gonna learn, you're gonna work.
She was that warm demander.
Racism gets in the way of that
because it often results
in lowered expectations.
It results in strained relationships.
And sometimes it results
in teachers who don't see
themselves as being
invested in the learner,
taking responsibility for whether or not
their students are actually learning.
So I think it's important that
we have an equity mindset,
and we recognize that
professional educators
have a moral and
professional responsibility
to educate all their students.
And if they can't, they
need to let someone know,
I've got a kid in my
class who's not learning,
and they need to call for help.
To do anything less, in my opinion,
is a form of malpractice.
And teachers should not be complicit
in allowing kids not to learn.
When you see kids end up
in high school or college
who haven't learned basic math,
that means there were
educators all along the way
who saw it, and did nothing.
- And what advice would you,
I think everyone agrees intellectually,
but if you can imagine
you're a ninth grade teacher,
you have five kids in your class that are
barely struggling, you kind
of water it down for them,
they barely scratch by on a C.
They're gonna be those kids
who have to take remedial math,
if they even get through high
school and get to college.
But that teacher's feeling
like, hey, there's 30 kids here.
I gotta do what I can.
I told the administration,
the administration's kind of saying, look,
that's the way life is.
Like how does someone, from
a teacher's point of view,
or does it have to happen
at the systemic level?
How do we make sure that
there are ways to support those kids?
- Truthfully it's hard for
a teacher by themselves
to effect system change.
They can change what's
happening in their classroom.
They can create the
climate in their classroom,
where kids feel supported and engaged.
And the truth is that when
the classroom door closes,
the teachers have a lot of power,
at least one way in a
physical space together.
But to bring about real system
change, you need leaders,
principals, superintendents,
who understand that
we've gotta become better
at intervening early with
kids, better at providing,
some kids as you know Sal, need more time
than the traditional school day allows.
So we need to find ways to
create more time, as well,
for the kids on subjects
that take more time
for them to learn.
- Yeah, it's always blown my mind
that slow is equated with dumb,
when oftentimes the kids that
just need a little more time,
they're really trying to internalize it.
And if they have a strong
foundation, they're gonna,
we see that at Khan Academy
all the time in our own data.
So I couldn't agree with you more.
That equation is really flawed,
and it makes kids even
think that they're not smart
when they're fully capable.
- One of the what are the attributes
that kids most frequently
cite as being valuable to them
from a teacher, is patience.
Teachers who are patient
and giving them the chance
and teachers who are organized
in how they put them.
- No, I remember when I
was tutoring my cousins,
I mean, I tell the story all the time,
that when I first made some
of those videos for them,
they told me famously that
they liked me better on YouTube
than in person.
And I think part of it,
and I always try to parse
what they were saying,
'cause they weren't saying they
really appreciated having me
as like a real person
who is invested in them.
But I think the video comment
was really about the patience
that they didn't feel
the pressure to learn it
right in that three minutes,
that they could come
back to it, et cetera.
They had multiple opportunities.
- They could pause the video
and then pick it up again,
that's 'cause again, that's how we learn.
And we don't all learn at the same pace.
- No, couldn't agree more.
So the time we have left,
we have teachers watching
this, we have students,
we have a lot of parents,
and obviously everyone's got
a certain level of anxiety these days
above and beyond what they
normally would have had.
What advice do you have about
where education is going?
How people should navigate it?
Any big takeaways?
- Yeah, I'd say right
now we have to use again,
use this disruption to
start thinking about
what kind of schools do we wanna create?
What kind of classrooms
do we wanna create?
Start visualize what the
end should look like.
Imagine schools with kids who
are excited about learning,
where they were happy to come each day.
What would it take to create
those kinds of schools?
And let's start planning for that.
Let's start planning schools
where relationships are valued,
where we are thinking holistically
about the needs of kids,
the academic, the social,
the emotional needs of kids,
'cause they're all integrated.
And let's start thinking
about how to really organize
schools to meet the needs of our students.
If we did that, then I
think we would end up
with very different
schools than we have now.
- No, couldn't agree more.
And what I always stress is,
people view me as a technologist,
but I don't view myself that way.
I always say never use
technology for technology's sake.
Always think about what is the goal.
And 99% of the time, the
best possible resource
is an amazing in-person
teacher for your child.
And if technology can help
unlock what that teacher can do,
personalize more, fill in
gaps, mastery learning,
then that's all good.
But technology has to be
in service to the humans
and in service of those goals.
- Absolutely, I agree.
I couldn't agree more.
- Well, Dean Noguera, thank
you so much for joining.
This is one of those conversations
I think we could continue
for another several hours.
But I'll let you go for now.
But thank you so much for joining.
This was really valuable.
- And Sal, I wanna thank you
for the service you provide
to kids throughout the country,
and making education and
knowledge more accessible.
And I think you provided
just a tremendous resource
to so many, so thank you.
- No, well it's a lot more than me,
but I really appreciate that.
And I'm gonna follow up with you,
I think there's ways that
we could work together.
- That'd be great.
All the best.
- Yup, thank you.
Thanks everyone.
As always, Dean Noguera, was really great,
and I wish we had another
five hours to chat
because this is obviously
a really big subject.
But hopefully y'all got as
much out of that as I did.
Thanks for joining.
Just a couple of announcements.
We're gonna have my next livestream,
well actually it was on this
document that I was looking at,
but now it disappeared.
But we're gonna have that webinar
with our chief learning
officer, I believe it is,
oh, there it goes, all right yeah.
Seven tips for motivating
middle school and high schools
kids during distance learning.
This is going to be October
22nd, 4:00 PM, Pacific time.
I highly recommend it.
You're gonna really enjoy Kristen,
she's our chief learning officer.
Not only does she know almost
everything to know about
learning science, but she's
also really, really engaging.
So I think y'all will
really enjoy that webinar.
So with that, I will see y'all at
the next homeroom livestream,
talk to y'all later.
(chimes)